[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré au funérailles de la reine
Elizabeth II des funérailles du siècle
que vous avez pu suivre bien sûr le
cercueil arrivé sur un affût de canon de
la Royal Navy escorté par 142 marins la
cérémonie à l'abbaye de Westminster de
Londres en présence de plus de 200 chefs
d'États et de gouvernement l'archevêque
de canterberi chef spirituel de l'église
anglicane qui a rendu hommage à la vie
de la reine consacrée aux services de la
nation et du commonwears et à son
caractère joyeux l'inhumation a lieu au
château de Windsor après une nouvelle
cérémonie à la chapelle Saint-Georges
c'est funérailles d'Elisabeth II
marque-t-elle finalement la fin d'une
époque où au contraire la persistance
des traditions la présence de 200 chefs
d'états gouvernement donne-t-elle une
portée géopolitique assez funérailles
quel défi devra relever le roi à Charles
III on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à Philippe Chassaigne
bonsoir historien spécialiste du
Royaume-Uni professeur à l'université
Bordeaux Montaigne bienvenue dans le
débat en face de vous Christopher
chanterait bonsoir vous êtes britannique
ancien président du British community of
friends bienvenue à vous également
Frédéric donatal bonsoir rédacteur en
chef de la revue est dynastie bienvenue
dans le débat et puis nous avons avec
nous en duplex de Londres cuant pile
bonsoir à vous chercheurs associés au
programme Europe de Chattam house ancien
rédacteur en chef étrangère à faire
étrangère au finals bienvenue à vous
quanti piles on est ravi de vous
retrouver puisqu'on était ensemble à
Londres justement au lendemain du décès
de la reine avant de démarrer ce débat
je vous propose de regarder un florilège
de cette journée si particulière
ils sont venus du monde entier pour lui
rendre un dernier hommage le président
américain Joe Biden l'empereur du Japon
Naruto ou encore le président français
Emmanuel Macron
[Applaudissements]
dont l'abbaye de Westminster ce lundi le
cercueil d'Elizabeth II a entamé son
dernier voyage
face à lui l'archevêque de Canterbury
donne l'horizon funèbre le chef
spirituel de l'église anglicane s'allume
une vie entière consacrée au service de
la nation
dans un discours connu prononcé pour ses
21 ans sa défunte Majesté a déclaré que
sa vie entière serait consacrée au
service de la nation et du commonwear
rarement une promesse aurait été aussi
bien tenue peu de dirigeants ont reçu
l'effusion d'amour que nous avons vu
au cœur de cette abbaye intrinsèquement
lié au destin d'Elisabeth II ils sont
2000 invités à lui rendre un dernier
hommage la secrétaire général du
Commonwealth ou encore la chef du
gouvernement lustre ont prononcé des
prières
[Musique]
puis le Royaume-Uni se fige 2 minutes de
silence sont observés en mémoire
d'Élisabeth II
l'hymne national god save the king vient
ensuite mettre fin à cette cérémonie
pour ses premières funérailles d'État
depuis 1965
[Musique]
la procession se poursuit ensuite
jusqu'à l'Arc de Wellington avant de
gagner la chapelle Saint-Georges du
château de Windsor
ces funérailles achève Tintin national
marquée par une immense vague d'émotions
collectives depuis le décès le 8
septembre à 96 ans d'Elizabeth II dans
son château écossais de Balmoral
[Musique]
on va écouter à présent quelques
réactions à Londres
elle était notre reine elle était tout
pour nous je voulais juste dire au
revoir et présenter mes condoléances
l'atmosphère est incroyable on voulait
juste être présente et lui rendre
hommage
j'ai pensé que c'était la bonne chose et
la plus importante chose à faire de
venir ici pour rendre un dernier hommage
à la reine qui a servi notre pays
pendant tant d'années
c'était aussi important pour nous de
faire partie de cette atmosphère et de
cette émotion collective de toute notre
relation en ce jour très important
de cette journée est-ce que c'est la fin
d'une époque
oui je crois bien c'était une journée
très émouvante très bien organisée aussi
avec beaucoup de traditions qu'on voyait
traditions de ces affaires que les
Britanniques aiment beaucoup mais quand
même je trouve que c'est un moment très
difficile pour le nouveau roi pour
Charles III parce qu'il arrive justement
quand il quand il a une crise économique
énorme dans le pays et un gouvernement
tout à fait nouveau alors les gens du de
sa royaume sont assez divisés entre les
Anglais les Écossais les Irlandais et
tout et je trouve que ça va être très
difficile pour lui je vois un homme avec
le poids de l'histoire sur ses épaules
Christopher chantier le poids de
l'histoire donc il en parle déjà Quantin
Peel il est déjà en train de parler de
Charles III on n'a pas encore alors
qu'on était dans les funérailles ce qui
montre bien quand même cette continuité
de la royauté
continuité c'est justement une des
fonctions clés de la monarchie
britannique c'est le fait que la reine
meurt et tout de suite à l'instant même
Charles est devenu le roi on a su le
même soir que il allait prendre le nom
de Charles III et vous êtes d'accord
ça va être compliqué pour lui non je
pense qu'il a il a été à l'école de sa
mère et de sa grand-mère il a il a eu
une soixantaine d'années d'apprentissage
il sait exactement ce qu'on attend de
lui et comment faire maintenant qu'il
est roi donc je pense que les doutes qui
ont été exprimées par certains que c'est
sorti sur le l'environnement ou
l'architecture allait continuer alors je
pense que non je pense qu'il s'est
parfaitement quel rôle il doit jouer et
avec quelle discrétion avec la
discrétion de sa mère on va on va y
revenir Philippe Chassagne cela faisait
le deux siècles que l'abbaye de
Westminster n'avait pas accueilli de
funérailles royales pourquoi Elisabeth
II a-t-elle choisi cet endroit parce que
toute sa vie pratiquement est liée les
pays de Westminster donc c'est là
qu'elle s'est mariée c'est là qu'elle a
été couronnée et donc c'est là qu'elle
s'est funérailles ont été ont été
organisés mais pour ce qui est la
question juste précédente si je peux
revenir 2 secondes
en fait ce qui se passe c'est comme à la
fin du règne de Victoria 63 ans après 64
ans elle 70 ans nécessaire après des
règles très longs et a forcément une
période de réadaptation d'autant plus
que Charles se trouve être même plus âgé
que Édouard cell côté sur le trône dans
cette année 60 ans et Charles azum
bientôt 74 donc vous pensez tout de même
qu'il y aura sa marque la fin d'une
époque Frédéric donatal vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ah oui totalement alors
moi je vais même plus loin parce que
c'est 70 ans de règne qui donne cette
impression
je pense même qu'on enterre carrément
l'Histoire avec un grand H en tout cas
en l'occurrence a priori Elisabeth II a
quand même traversé tout le XXème siècle
elle était elle est née princesse
impériale elle elle décède à reine
d'Angleterre d'Irlande et d'Écosse avec
en tant que chef d'État du du
commonwealt donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui se tourne et puis
c'est un règne ce qu'on appelle le règne
élisabethin qui était assez propre à
Elisabeth II une façon de régner
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y a quand même
un peu de changement il y a un peu plus
de modernisme il suffit de regarder
Charles qui est parti faire des bains de
full c'est les semaines embrasser ce que
la reine n'aurait jamais permis de son
vivant donc je pense que c'est autre
chose donc plus chaleureux un peu plus
chaleureux du moins je pense qu'il a
compris que il fallait avancer dans le
temps pour que la monarchie reste
pérenne tout simplement donc et c'est
aussi ça la force de la monarchie si
vous voulez c'est qu'elle est capable de
s'adapter en toute circonstances et en
tout temps et en même temps on a vu
toutes ces traditions exceptionnelles
aujourd'hui donc c'est tradition sans
l'Angleterre ne serait rien sans ces
tradition et la encore moins elle a
besoin de ça vous savez il y a ce côté
très moderne où il faut avancer dans le
temps et puis il faut aussi garder un
peu cette traditions là la Monarchie
c'est un lien entre le passé et le
présent il faut bien s'en souvenir elle
elle est dans une idée de continuité
comme
il a bien été exprimé tout à l'heure et
c'est ça qu'il faut retenir donc même si
Charles amen cette idée de modernité il
restera toujours un peu de passer et
finalement c'est ce aussi dont on besoin
les populations pouvoir s'en créer à
leur passé historique Quantin pizza
qu'on a été ébloui par toutes ces
traditions aujourd'hui liste a pris la
parole tout de même elle a en fait
exprimé une prière à la cérémonie à
l'abbaye de Westminster pourquoi est-ce
que c'est pour symboliser aussi
finalement la démocratie en même temps
que la monarchie
je me demande si
ce qu'on voulait voir aujourd'hui
c'était bien sûr la continuité bien sûr
que le roi Charles et le prochain
monarque et il va suivre sa mère mais je
crois pour les jeunes Britanniques
toutes ces traditions sont
irrévantes en effet il ne comprennent
pas ils ont
ils ont une monarchie ils ne sont pas
des romantiques les jeunes j'ai parlé
avec mes propres enfants ils n'ont même
pas regardé la télévision aujourd'hui je
trouve ça dommage donc il y a une
différence générationnelle c'est ce que
vous dites
les jeunes ils sont beaucoup moins
sensibles
à cette monarchie oui je crois bien oui
oui c'est ça et ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi alors c'est parce que c'est
vraiment les soldats les traditions
militaires qu'on voyait aujourd'hui
pour les jeunes c'est séparé les vent et
pour eux c'est la courte vie et
l'inflation et tout ça alors qu'est-ce
qui fait pour mais il a la seule chose
où il voit que le roi Charles est
élevant et avec sa passion pour
l'environnement ça c'est très important
alors peut-être que si vraiment il
souligne cette patient
pour l'environnement
il va quand même unifier le pays et ils
vont suivre
d'attente on voyait qu'il y avait toutes
les générations
tous les tous les sexes et toutes les
couleurs de peau donc en fait je pense
ce que dit monsieur est tout à fait
pertinent mais en fait il n'y a pas les
jeunes c'est qu'il y a différents
segments dans cette population jeune et
le pire le l'attrait que
la reine Elizabeth II exerçait sur un
large éventail de la population et pas
tout à fait importante je veux dire que
c'était 7,77 ans je crois que c'est
quand même à peu près cela Christophe
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire tout de même quanti il y a une
différence entre les générations
je pense qu'il fallait souligner le fait
que dans cette fameuse file d'attente il
y avait il y avait tout le monde ou des
représentants de tout le monde ça semble
750 000 personnes c'est un échantillon
considérable il faut aussi souligner
dans les fonctions de la monarchie
britannique c'est ce rapport direct avec
la population que la population n'a pas
de la part du gouvernement
on ne ferait pas ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui pour un homme politique ou
une femme politique on l'a fait parce
que c'est une règne une reine qui a eu
un règne très long mais surtout pendant
cette période de 70 ans elle a elle fait
tout pour avoir le contact et inspirer
la population ce que ne font pas les
présidents dans les républiques ce que
ne font pas les politiques dans un
régime parlementaire comme le
Royaume-Uni mais ce qui est intéressant
tout de même Frédéric donatel c'est que
list Trust a parlé à l'abbaye de
boissy-sur-seur je reviens un peu à ça
et là elle a elle a elle a fait une
prière elle a été la deuxième d'ailleurs
à s'exprimer à l'abbaye Westminster donc
est-ce que ça symbolise la présence de
la démocratie ou pas déjà pour commencer
démocratie monarchie ne sont absolument
pas du tout antinomique oui parce qu'on
est dans la monarchie constitutionnelle
mais c'est intéressant de voir que c'est
la première ministre s'est exprimée
c'est un protocole donc tout est
minimitri il y a pas véritablement une
si vous voulez un symbole par le fait
que ce soit exprimé en second on aurait
pu être en troisième en quatrième ce
n’aurait pas changé grand chose ce qui
est plus intéressant effectivement c'est
comme vous l'avez bien souligné c'est
que la reine a un rôle certes
constitutionnel mais est un arbitre
naturel il faut pas oublier que ça dans
nos démocraties actuelles en tout cas
dans nos républiques c'est peut-être
aussi ce qu'il manque énormément et qui
fait que on a beaucoup de mal à se
reconnaître dans des valeurs ou dans
certains leaders or la reine
d'Angleterre incarnait un roc une
stabilité une incarnation de de la
monarchie et de tradition dans laquelle
chacun pouvait s'y retrouver quel que
soit les générations et c'est ce qui
explique aussi pourquoi il y a ce
engouement et toutes ces diverses
générations que l'on a vu sur des
kilomètres pour aller rendre hommage à
l'arène à juste pour s'incliner ce qui
est assez extraordinaire ce qu'on ne
ferait absolument pas du tout pour un
président de la République en France un
milliard de téléspectateurs
manifestement des cérémonies aujourd'hui
dans le monde
allez-y plus que ça peut-être mais il
faut dire aussi que le plan le
protocole des funérailles ça a été régie
rédigé il y a des années des années donc
ce petit détail tout était prévu donc là
pourquoi l'histoire a pris la parole
c'est parce que sur le le protocole
c'était le premier ministre l'IRA la
première leçon elle est un texte de la
Bible par une prière c'était pas une
prière le texte de la Bible mais c'était
c'était prévu depuis longtemps que le
premier ministre ou la première ministre
mais ce n'était pas un hasard sinon tu
es prévu
c'est le chef du gouvernement qui qui et
puis après le secrétaire
du Common c'était en premier
doit
accorderception de la monarchie puisque
le roi ou la reine possède un double
corps c'est ça donc il y a le corps
terrestre mortel et le corps politique
et immortel et est-ce que d'ailleurs ça
n'est pas symbolisé par la couronne
qu'on l'enlève du cercueil c'est à dire
que vous avez en fait cette séparation
des deux corps Philippe Chassagne
parce que de toute façon ils vont être
utilisés pour le couronnement de
Charlotte III mais oui les deux corps
mais les deux corps du roi c'est bien la
reine est morte vive le Roi et donc à
partir du moment comme disait au bout de
décédé automatiquement son fils est
devenu
enfin est devenu Charles III c'est bien
ça qu'on appelle les deux cordules
et le corps spirituel symbolique
qwant
quels sont vraiment les pouvoirs du roi
ou de la reine est-ce que finalement
c'est un pouvoir d'influence tout de
même par exemple on ne saura jamais ce
que la reine a dit pendant toutes ces
années au Premier ministre ou à la
première ministre qu'elle voyait chaque
année lors de ses entretiens est-ce que
finalement elle a une influence elle a
eu une influence plus grande que ce
qu'on aurait pu imaginer
je crois que l'influence est alors le
vrai pouvoir du monarque de la reine ou
de du moins cher maintenant
c'est pas grand parce qu'effectivement
le pouvoir est avec le gouvernement le
Premier ministre qui ou la première
ministre qui est effectivement comme un
président dans un autre pays mais
seulement pour peut-être
essayer de calmer les divisions c'est
important je crois que le Manar qui est
très important pour l'unité du pays
alors c'est à dire s'il a un débat
maintenant qu'on a on Écosse sur
l'indépendance mais si les Écossais
veulent garder le roi le même roi que
les Britanniques ça pourrait être aider
mais ça ça c'est un pouvoir très
difficile à
exploiter et je crois que
le roi Charles doit être très sensible
à la politique mais ne jamais se mêler
dedans un mot peut-être sur la présence
des 200 chefs d'États et de gouvernement
Christopher chantier qui fait que
finalement c'est une sorte de portée
géopolitique assez funérailles Vladimir
Poutine n'était pas invité parce
qu'effectivement il a envahi l'Ukraine
donc pas question de l'invité il y avait
la Birmanie n'était pas invité la Syrie
la Corée du Nord mais sinon il y a une
il y avait une délégation chinoise donc
pas si Jinping mais son vis président
qui était représenté Joe Biden est
arrivé dans sa limousine donc lui il a
dérogé un certain nombre enfin au
protocole puisqu'on demandait justement
aux personnalités politiques de prendre
le bus tout ça ça fait partie
effectivement du protocole mais ça donne
presque à une dimension géopolitique à
l'événement c'est une dimension
extraordinaire on a dit de la reine
qu'elle était la première diplomate du
pays voir du monde parce que qui d'autre
pourrait organiser quelque chose comme
ça en
quelque sorte enfin j'obs je suis fier
parce que je suis britannique mais c'est
c'est
beaucoup plus grand que le pays lui-même
c'est un essai extraordinaire de levier
que
cet événement a produit vous avez le
pouvoir vous-même même surpris par la
portée de cet événement de oui parce que
je suis conscient disons du déclin
relatif de mon pays sur les années
depuis la guerre et surtout depuis le
brexit c'est alors le gouvernement
actuel essaye de
pas le montrer il y a eu un ministre
dans le gouvernement par le shanson qui
est censé
et être responsable des bienfaits du
brexit donc il y a un compte finalement
il en a trouvé 9 donc il y a un
contraste finalement entre ce déclin
tout de même palpable du Royaume-Uni et
finalement ce côté grandiose de ces
funérailles Philippe Chassaigne là
encore précédent qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est la reine Victoria et ça va attiré
l'empereur du Japon était une autre
époque là on était c'est une c'était une
19e une même figure aussi centrale et
pour ce qui est la
elizabething il y avait un empire
maintenant il y a davantage de chef
d'État de des pays africains qui étaient
des colonies qui maintenant sont devenus
des républiques plus ou moins
authentique enfin bon donc dès que l'on
aisations un mécaniquement augmenter le
nombre des des chefs d'États qui sont
venus assister à cette assez funérailles
et n'oublions pas non plus que la reine
Élisabeth II lorsqu'elle fait ses
visites d'État en dehors des pays du
communistes la plus marge de manœuvre
mais elle va là où le gouvernement lui
dit d'aller parce que elle est un
ambassadeur de la politique étrangère de
la grande vague Elizabeth II c'était un
c'était l'incarnation du soft power donc
le pouvoir souple pour savoir power
désormais donc de la Grande-Bretagne
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un contraste
donc vous êtes d'accord Frédéric de
Natal entre justement la puissance
réelle et se déclin finalement du
Royaume-Uni notamment depuis le brexit
et puis
cet impact l'impact de ces funérailles
d'Elisabeth II c'est pour ça qu'on parle
peut-être de fin d'une époque aussi
alors oui c'est certes parce que c'est
très représentatif effectivement le
nombre de chefs d'État rendez-vous
compte même l'empereur du Japon c'est
quand même déplacé ce qui est
extrêmement rare un empereur du Japon ne
se déplace que pour les funérailles
errantes à sa famille là on a quand même
le fils du siège qui arrive directement
un avion pour assister à des funérailles
donc c'est dire la puissance et l'aura
qu'avait Elisabeth II à travers le monde
escalin carnet alors effectivement on
pourra toujours
ergoter sur la fin de ce que ça peut
représenter je voudrais juste rebondir
sur une chose concernant le fait que la
Russie n'était pas invitée il faut se
rappeler qu'en tant que Prince de Galles
le roi Charles a pris position contre la
Russie la vie publiquement comme son son
fils on en a beaucoup parlé il aurait
été quand même un petit peu bizarre que
la Russie soit invitée alors que la
Grande-Bretagne enfin du moins le
Royaume-Uni s'est aligné sur la position
européenne concernant
la Russie en russe en Ukraine et au même
titre d'ailleurs que ce soit la Birmanie
la Biélorussie la Syrie qui n'était pas
invité l'Afghanistan parce qu'il a pas
eu que deux il y a eu le CV Venezuela
qui était pas du tout
invité ça me paraît je crois au total
c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs on va
pouvoir voir maintenant si Charles
effectivement va faire ce qu'il a il
avait dit peu de temps avant
c'est-à-dire que en tant que Prince de
Galles il s'exprimait un peu plus
publiquement maintenant en tant que roi
il va peut-être rester un peu dans la
réserve on va voir quand sa mère en tout
cas avait un credo qui était never
expérimenter toute savoir si ça va être
trans
n'expliquez jamais et ne vous plaignez
jamais quanti piles justement votre
réaction face à tous ces chefs d'État
chef de gouvernement Joe Biden Emmanuel
Macron tous les autres leur présence
justement aujourd'hui à Londres
alors c'était très important pour le
Royaume-Uni que tous ces gens tous ces
grands présidents sont venus pour
donner hommage effectivement à la reine
mais en même temps je trouve que le
Royaume-Uni a beaucoup de problèmes
maintenant à ce présenter dans le monde
après brexit parce que il faut trouver
une nouvelle politique étrangère et
vraiment ce n'est pas clair que les
autres dans le monde vont écouter vont
écouter autant à la grande au
Royaume-Uni postbrexit que le
Royaume-Uni qui est membre de l'Union
européenne alors ça va être difficile
pour le nouveau gouvernement
Johnson et du brexit est-ce que ça fait
pas justement référence à cette belle
époque grande époque du Royaume-Uni
justement donc celui du règne du début
du règne en tout cas d'Elisabeth II
alors je trouve que les autres pays du
monde
alors ne voient pas global brut comme un
empire ou quelque chose comme ça mais
plutôt
un pouvoir moyen qui essaie de se
présenter dans le monde alors nous avons
quand même perdu beaucoup d'influence je
crois en quittant l'Union européenne
vous êtes d'accord
de ce plateau mais bon c'est un choix
qui est britanniques ont fait
c'est un choix
forte avec le commonwears avec justement
tous ces pays qui ne sont pas dans
l'Europe économiquement ça ne marche pas
parce que c'est payant c'est trop loin
et il y a trop de contraintes et à
l'exportation et à l'importation donc
le déclin est dont j'ai parlé c'est
également économique à cause du brexit
et vous n'avez pas remplacer le marché
européen par le marché australien il n'y
a pas assez de monde et c'est trop loin
en tout cas c'est parce qu'il disait
Boris Johnson à l'époque où
les conservateurs
pour le maintien
pour en revanche campagne pour la sortie
fiche justement ce qui a été vendu au
Britannique en 2016 au mandatum sur le
brexit c'était aux entité donc l'Union
européenne et puis on va renouer avec
tous les pays de langue de langue
anglaise de l'anglosphère qui associer
les les pays du Commonwealths les donc
les anciens dominions Canada serait une
Nouvelle-Zélande des pays qui ont
l'anglais comme seconde langue
officielle l'Inde les pays où l'anglais
largement pratiqués les pays du
Moyen-Orient
il faut quand même voir les choses en
face vous imaginez surtout aujourd'hui
après 2003 les pays du Moyen-Orient en
Irak
se précipiter devant la campagne a signé
des accords commerciaux avec eux ils
supportent plus les Britanniques ils les
ont occupés l'Inde elle a d'autres
priorités que de
louer une relation commerci au final
prioritaire enfin essentiel avec la
grandeur la Chine vers les États-Unis
c'est la même chose pour l'Australie qui
est quand même très attiré aussi par le
le modèle américain d'abord c'est plus
proche des États-Unis de l'Australie que
le Royaume-Uni Frédéric de natales qui
va y avoir un réveil un peu difficile
demain au Royaume-Uni
c'est probable en même temps la
politique bon ça a été mise de la
politique politicienne a été mise un peu
de côté le temps de ces
il y a 10 jours de vraiment le monde
était suspendu à ces traditions
britanniques oui et puis et puis tout va
recommencer demain et Charles III va
être certainement confronté à divers
problèmes donc effectivement on a ce
problème économique qui sévit en
Grande-Bretagne et comme il s'est dit
d'ailleurs en France et dans d'autres
pays d'Europe et puis il va y avoir le
maintien de l'Union également puisque
les causes poussent enfin souhaiteraient
en tout cas organiser un référendum très
consultatif l'Irlande du Nord en tout
cas une partie des Néerlandais
souhaiterait que l'Irlande soit
complètement unifiée et là d'ailleurs on
part sur des problématiques qui
proviennent d'ailleurs du brexit
puisqu'il y a des problèmes de douane de
TVA accès excès etc il faut quand même
pas oublier non plus que quand il y a eu
ce référendum sur le brexit l'Écosse et
l'Irlande du Nord ont été les deux pays
qui ont voté contre la sortie de la
Grande-Bretagne du Royaume-Uni alors que
l'Angleterre et le pays de Galles ont
été très favorable donc l'extérieur
versus l'intérieur c'est assez
intéressant ce décalage entre le Nord le
Sud qui est qui qui a eu et ça Charles
va devoir à l'affronter en plus des
problématiques au sein du Commonwealth
parce qu'il y a des vérités
indépendantistes assez fortes et assez
clair et encore avec la nuance allez-y
wifi ça saigne oui
donc ils peuvent demander l'indépendance
la Jamaïque va probablement enfin j'ai
pas de vin
pourrait suivre le le chemin de la
Barbade ça proclamer République l'année
dernière on a vu qu'en Australie donc il
y a eu un ministère et un ministre qui
était nommé à la ministre à la
République mais s'il a jamais que
devient une république si le soleil a
une république elle n'en resteront pas
moins si elle le désire membre du coup
maintenant parce que rassemble aussi des
républiques des monarchies absolues
notamment dans les le sultanat de Brunei
etc c'est ce qui s'est passé au Barbade
elle fait toujours partie alors qu'elle
est devenue une république mais le lien
dynastique rompre la nia dynastic ne
n’entraîne pas automatiquement à la
sortie du commun Noël la preuve c'est
qu'un nouveau pays qui entre le
communisme qui n'ont même jamais été des
colonies britanniques
est-ce que justement le vrai défi l'un
des grands défis en tout cas pour
Charles III ça sera de maintenir le
Royaume Uni c'est-à-dire que
effectivement l'Écosse qui devrait
organiser un référendum finalement que
le référendum ne bascule pas vers le
désir d'indépendance et puis après il y
a l'Irlande bien sûr la question
irlandaise
[Musique]
mais alors justement qu'est-ce que ça
signifie du coup à Christopher
d'ailleurs sur une question en fait une
question mineure relativement mineur qui
fait que et c'est une question de
sous de dépenses
je connais plus le détail peut-être nous
dire mais en tout cas ça va être l'un
des défis
de faire en sorte que le royaume reste
unique il n'y ait pas que l'Écosse ne
sorte pas et ensuite l'Irlande le
gouvernement de Londres donc le
gouvernement du Royaume-Uni la ligne
qu'elle adore qu'elle a adoptée toujours
depuis toujours c'est pas de référendum
il y a déjà eu un en 2014 on attend une
génération moi je dis que s'il y a un
référendum qui a pour conséquence
possible la désunification du pays il
faut que tous les Britanniques puissent
voter dedans pas que les Écossais si
le décide
il y a un référendum qui pourrait avoir
comme conséquence la désunification du
pays il faut que tous les intéressés
puissent voter y compris les Français
des Britanniques de l'étranger mais pour
toute façon pour que le référendum ait
lieu en Écosse il faut la sentiment me
semble-t-il effectivement
tout le monde devrait pouvoir voter
parce que une conséquence serait la
signification
c'est tout le problème des écossais qui
ne les années 80 refuse ce pliure règne
de la démocratie parce que ils sont
minorité démographiquement minoritaires
et donc ce qui s'est passé c'est pour ça
que Marie Thatcher a été réélu à 4
reprises fallu à quatre reprises parce
que en ayant on perdant à chaque fois
des des sièges des sièges en Écosse mais
l'Angleterre c'est démographique sur la
nation la plus peuplée des cannations
constitutives du coup c'est son vote qui
c'est son vote qui pèse donc les
Écossais vont dire oui mais si les
Anglais votent mais dans ce cas ne
seront jamais indépendants mais s'il
décide de d'organiser ce référendum nous
n'obstant l'opposition de Londres à
faire ses sessions et je suis très
surpris depuis des années mais bon c'est
pas une personne devant c'est écossais
ces membres d'un pays qui contestent les
résultats des élections au niveau
national parce que le reste du pays ne
vote pas comme eux
vous savez je crois que les défis que
nous vont devoir va devoir affronter
Charles III ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes d'une région à une autre alors les
causes effectivement est incapable il y
a bien séparatisme qui existe depuis des
années maintenant aujourd'hui tous les
sondages laissent présumé que le nom
serait toujours gagnant s'il y avait un
référendum référendum qui doit être
organisant 2023 mais qui n'est que
consultatif donc ça n'a pas
véritablement effectivement de grande
valeur puisqu'il y a eu celui de 2014 la
position de de Londres est vraiment
celle qui a été édité par Monsieur
Chantry tout à l'heure c'est à dire mais
il y a eu un référendum point barre là
où je suis plus inquiet par contre c'est
au niveau de l'Irlande du Nord parce que
le gouvernement actuel le shinfen n'a
que deux sièges de différence avec les
Unionistes unionist qui n'entendent
absolument pas du tout céder un pouce au
niveau de la réunification et qui se
battront pour que ça reste et s'il
l'Irlande devait partir cela signifie
quoi fin du Royaume-Uni et sans
Royaume-Uni pas de Grande-Bretagne à les
élus ont au total donc le risque il est
pour moi plus du côté de l'Irlande du
Nord que de l'Écosse à proprement parler
que de l'Écosse
est-ce qu'il faudrait que Charles III
réformes la monarchie également on a
beaucoup parlé du train de vie elle
s'est déjà un peu réformée il me semble
à deux reprises avec la reine Elizabeth
II comment est-ce qu'il pourrait
réformer la monarchie pour justement et
bien faire en sorte que les jeunes dont
vous nous parliez et bien adhère
finalement à cette monarchie soit plus
proche d'elle
je crois qu'il doit alors il il va faire
un effort pour ouvrir la monarchie pour
être plus transparent je crois et aussi
il doit réduire peut-être les les
personnes de la famille royale qui sont
sur le qui qui sont pour le le qui font
des
pardon qui vont
la famille royale est trop grande la
famille royale est trop grande il y a
trop de monde là-dedans qui sont payés
effectivement par le par le public par
les payeurs de taxes alors il faut
réduire le nombre de la famille royale
et en même temps vous faites ça parce
que
c'est pas simple de réduire le nombre
comment vous les sélectionner
la famille royale alors si on a
peut-être une famille de une dizaine de
personnes plus c'est pas les beaucoup de
cousins et d'autres qui vont je trouve
que il doit faire quelque chose dans
cette direction qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Christopher Christopher
le coup le coup par habitant de la
famille royale et j'ai vu un chiffre
récemment enfin c'est quelques centimes
de 89 centimes
par personne
de pas en France même si c'était une
livre par personne par an ce n'est pas
cher ah oui mais alors pourtant on a
beaucoup parlé du train de vie c'est
étonnant que vous disiez ça parce que le
train de vie de la famille royale c'est
quand même un sujet c'est divisé par 65
millions donc tu habites si c'est pas
ravitant c'est
pour vous c'est pas un sujet unitaire
est faible c'est pas un sujet Philippe
Chassaigne donc ce qui a remplacé la
liste civile c'est l'équivalent de 199
millions d'euros donc voilà et on a une
population 67 millions d'habitants donc
on voit bien que ramener comme vous le
disiez à la ou au nombre de Britanniques
ça fait peu n'oublions pas non plus que
il faudrait réduire un polytran de vie
en réduisant le nombre de la famille 2
avait déjà réduit le nombre des
bénéficiaires de la liste civils qui
étaient recentrés sur donc elle le
le duc d'Édimbourg et donc Charles et
ses enfants et c'était la reine qui
versait les allocations aux autres
membres de la famille donc il y a déjà
eu cet élément de streamlining
d'amincissement de la de la monarchie et
faut pas oublier non plus il ne faut pas
oublier non plus que si on effectue 3000
ou 4000 engagements par an si on fait
retourner solaire sur 4 personnes elles
vont être partout du pays du matin au
soir et du salon matin donc pas non plus
trop réduire la famille royale parce
qu'il faut que l'autre ou alors il
faudra diminuer les engagements
officiels hors une des justifications
après de la monarchie c'est que il doit
y avoir ces engagements officiel
l'engagement caritatif etc donc voyez
une question qui est assez complexe et
les c'est pour ça que bon les
républicains qui parlent tout le temps
du coup de la monarchie bon je trouve
que c'est
ils ont fait le droit d'avoir cet
argument là c'est un argument qui ne
repose pas sur une étude
serrée de la de la situation comptable
alors après la question la fortune
personnelle de la reine c'est autre
chose mais en l'occurrence
la fortune de Charles puisqu'elle vérité
de sa mère mais ça ce sont des des
sympatrimantes personnelles qui est qui
est lié à une gestion optimale et
optimisée de placement
financier placement immobilier etc mais
bon qui on regarde ça là la reine
Élisabeth II elle était même pas dans
les 300 premiers plus riches personne de
Grande-Bretagne alors que quand elle
montait sur le trône elle était la
première ce qui pourrait par exemple
donner un peu plus de place au plus
jeune Charles III son fils en
l'occurrence ça va être le cas c'est un
des piliers de de la monarchie alors la
question c'est certes très complexe pour
qu'on ait l'impression tout de même un
rajeunissement parce qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment mais Charles III à 73 ans
c'est pas une question d'âge en soi
c'est une institution mais sur l'image
l'image peu importe l'âge il faut savoir
faire le job déjà déjà avant tout c'est
déjà la première chose on peut avoir 73
ans et le faire correctement en avoir 30
de faire tout aussi correctement là la
question si vous voulez qui certes
complexe alors certes on dit beaucoup
que Charles va restreindre ce qu'on
appelle le Cercle Royal il se
concentrerait uniquement sur quelques
personnages de la famille parce que
c'est vrai que 48% 48 personnes à
Buckingham face sur le balcon de
Buckingham ne représente pas grand chose
10 c'est peut-être un peu plus visible
là on parle beaucoup de William nouveau
prince de Galles qui serait beaucoup mis
en avant lui-même a dit d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui pourrait faire justement
William pour être mis en avant en
particulier mais il n'a pas duré
d'autres de nouvelles missions mais il a
pas besoin de d'être
d'avoir de nouvelles missions idée le
prince héritier il représente la nation
ou qu'il aille il fera exactement ce que
fait son père également et c'est ça qui
est le plus important c'est le rôle que
la monarchie a et l'image qu'elle donne
ce sont faut pas oublier quand même ce
sont des chefs d'État enfin le roi
Charles 3 est un chef d'État il
représente son pays le prince héritier
en sera c'est un métier et ça et ça ça
prend et et tout ça retranscrit dans ce
qu'on voit à travers les images donc pas
une histoire de rajeunissement ou pas la
monarchie elle reste pérenne et elle
traverse les siècles elle n'a pas d'âge
elle est intemporelle quending pile vous
êtes d'accord elle est intemporelle donc
ces questions de rajeunissement ou de
train de vie moins moins importante ce
n'est pas vraiment une question pour
vous ça en est une manifestement
oui je crois rajeunissement c'est c'est
d'excellence si on suit le chemin vers
le prince William maintenant le prince
égal et s'il pourrait effectivement
suivre un peu plus le chemin de son père
c'est-à-dire l'environnement des
engagements comme ça et son père si il
suit la reine et alors s'il ne parle pas
autant de la politique mais plutôt
seulement il a été un symbole pour la
nation ça pourrait être ça pourrait
marcher alors le prince William est très
très aimé dans le je trouvais il a il a
suivi un chemin dans sa vie
beaucoup plus proche aux jeunes de
britannique que son père
de du prince will
mais je pense qu'effectivement il pourra
prendre le relais de son père pour
parler de certains sujets qui sont des
sujets importants sans qu'on puisse dire
que c'est qu'il en tant que Prince
d'égal qui n'a pas le droit de les
évoquer parce que le changement
de réserves
[Musique]
Elizabeth II non Charles restera dans le
dans le devoir de réserve à mon avis
William comme il est maintenant prince
égal il pourrait peut-être suivre son
pays son père en parlant de certains
sujets comme les sujets sensibles qui
sont
[Musique]
parce que les mécaniques reconnaissaient
son équilibre caritative comme pour la
princesse Sand d'ailleurs mais bon on
parlait de sondage tout à l'heure en une
semaine le prince Charles a connu un bon
dans le sondage d'opinion sa popularité
a connu un bon concert maintenant il est
donc il a bien commencé oui il est en
deuxième position derrière son fils qui
a 80 % et lui il le choix qui nous donne
son âge il a 73 % de popularité
d'opinion favorable c'est qu'il y a
quand même pas mal alors qu'avant il
était aux alentours de 50% donc c'est un
bon démarrage oui
après certes on est dans l'émotion faut
pas l'oublier donc forcément ça joue un
petit peu le tout le tout de savoir s'il
va réussir à capitaliser ce taux de
popularité et qu'il n'a jamais atteint
quand il était prince de Galles parce
que c'est vrai que son fils William
passer largement avant lui bon il
formait avec Kate Middleton un couple
très glamour donc qui pouvait parler à
beaucoup de personnes Charles avait
l'air un petit peu taciturne caractériel
un peu d'honneur de leçons etc ça
pouvait agacer les Britanniques on peut
le comprendre mais en même temps il a il
a il a probablement montré qu'il était
capable de gérer on lui doit quand même
des fermes écologiques que ce soit en
Bretagne ou même d'ailleurs en Roumanie
puisqu'il en a il s'occupe de ça enfin
il est ancré dans la réalité tout en
restant dans la tradition ça reste
toujours la force de la monarchie c'est
ça la transmission on est véritablement
dans une continuité
il va y avoir une sorte de gueule de
bois après ses 12 jours ou 10 jours
pendant lesquels on était suspendus à
toutes ces traditions et des demandes on
va il va être question sociale il va
être question inflation et c'est
listrots qui sera à nouveau je dirais
sur le devant de la scène
je crois tout de suite ça va revenir
parce que la crise n'est pas disparue et
ça va être une automne
à la très dur je crois avant nous alors
vraiment on a eu un peu de pause
seulement dans la crise maintenant pour
ces funérailles mais après ça va revenir
et pour l'histoire c'est un défi énorme
comment
unifier le pays et si Charles peut aider
à unifier le pays alors ça pourrait
aller bien mais je m'en doute merci
beaucoup cantine pile d'avoir été avec
nous merci beaucoup Frédéric de Natal
merci à vous aussi Chassagne merci
Christopher centry et merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis vous restez avec
nous sur France 24
[Musique]